optical illusions huh what do you see
what i promise there's a hidden image in
this
let's see if i can spot it first this is
a joke oh i think i saw something what
the [ __ ]
no i don't see anything what am i
talking about
[Music]
what is this harambe oh no i don't see
him oh what no there's no harambe
oh oh oh i
oh there he is what he just
what whoa super good see him he lives
oh that's trippy as hell dude what a
great one to start with
no way dude no
[Music]
or yes when she said no
no okay all the balls
are actually the same color get outta
here
oh my god they are no not the green they
are all the same color
look at one and then look at the other
one
you can tell they're all the same color
but if you look at the whole image oh
that's cool
all right what about this this is just
one person not
oh my god
oh wow we're living in the future
nothing is what it seems is biker
guy on ma the man biker even real
oh i've seen this one this one is
fantastic
now you know that it's turning around in
circles
in fact if you look at it from above you
can see that it's turning around in a
circle
but i'm with you our brain is doing
something strange it's telling you
that it's not going around in a circle
but it's oscillating in other words it's
turning part way
stop get out of my head dumpert
how did he do that just by telling me
going back the other way
now that's a strange effect isn't it but
if you think that's strange
wait till i add something through the
middle what am i going to add
well i'm going to add a ballpoint pen oh
no this is when it gets
weird i've placed a little piece of
double-sided sticky tape on the
ballpoint pen
you can use ordinary sticky tape if you
like i'll place it right through the
center of the window
and press it in place like that now this
time
by fixing on the pen you'll be able to
see
that the pen is okay here it comes here
comes or you're going to see something
strange we'll have a look at that that's
unbelievable isn't it
you can see the pen going around in a
circle but your brain is telling you
that the window is
going part way around and turning and
going the other way
[Music]
the two things have to pass through one
another the pen and the window you know
it's not possible you know it can't
happen
and yet as you look at it you see them
going through
alive what if i pause at the time okay
all right
how how did we get there i go around oh
my god
this video is hacked it's hacking my
brain download nordvpn to not get hacked
okay what is this dog appears to walk
through wall at first blitz second
[Laughter]
amazing wow equally incredible
love it a tunnel of light
what do we have here then whoa
wow at least this one i can't my brain
can understand
what is happening the other ones is just
stop get out of my mind that's really
cool though
a wholesome pic turned into an illusion
all right i like that poor water on
ground
step away from water congratulations you
are now levitation
wow
i like this i want to try this cover the
sides to go slower cover the middle to
go
faster okay well we're going we're going
faster if i cover the middle
yeah but this is a reference point okay
my brain understands
i'm not impressed hey
these are all so freaky i don't i don't
feel comfortable
at all i had oh stop
because your peripherals are looking at
two different
faces your brain combines that and
creates a demon
oh god stop combining oh god demons
actually ah wow that was freaky one
i can't tell if i'm being trolled or not
are they actually showing creepy people
are they just celebrities i can't tell
whoa
whoa i gotta see what it actually looked
like that was
cool that's so tricky freaked me out
okay so it's not just me i don't know
why but this illusion doesn't work for
me anymore huh
yeah i think if you try too hard you
have to really relax
relax your mind it takes a lot of
intellect to turn off your brain
like it does for me all right are blue
and yellow rectangles moving together or
alternate deeply watch closely as the
background turns gray
they are moving together which i know is
the answer but that's not what my brain
is telling me
i hate these okay sure okay let's see
the gray oh wow they're
moving wow oh wow hold up i know a cool
one
our peripheral has a blind spot i didn't
think this was real
this is from asap science
if you close your left eye stare at this
crosshair with your right eye
and slowly move your head towards or
away from the screen
the dot will disappear revealing the
exact location of your blind spot
there it is the cells at the back of
your eye transform light into cells
that are sent to your brain that is
tricky try it
that is weird it's so big how do i not
see it i understand blind spot
peripheral bad brain
move your head towards or away from the
screen okay turns my head away from the
screen
i can't see it now wow wait what
happened to did my camera fall
uh that one's trippy here i'll show
another tricky one i thought
okay so look at this picture you see a
regular stairs
okay and as i flip it over you still see
the stairs
and then you blink and it moves does
that make sense
all right flip it back normal stairs
flip
it side blink and then it changes
i can't you need to do it on a [ __ ]
phone i forgot my bad
oh it's one of those where it never
appears you think it's going down
i can tell it's going up i can tell
i'm not dumb you're dumb
shut up japanese optical illusion damn
you japanese
oh ow ow ow
why do people make this stop it
no no all the classic
nobody drunk pandas you have to scroll
for this to work looks like they're
moving how many times do they rotate in
total
zero shut up
wonderful you got this just like you
rehearsed i have the tiger
is it just me or is the sun giving this
guy our shoulder rope
beautiful that's a wonderful optical
illusion
i feel like i remember seeing this whoa
the framer of my camera makes it look
like a splinter sprinkler is sucking the
water
oh no it's a towel on her head
that is horrible that is awful
oh god i saw i i didn't see the towel
first i'm like what the [ __ ] is this
weird image and then
i read the caption thanks i hate towels
oh man
i know oh god i didn't even oh
oh what is this now i'm scared what's
gonna happen
has it happened already i can't tell
mate
what is it
okay yeah sure a bit basic
but it's homemade so i appreciate no way
so we see what's moving right but as
soon as it pauses
you can't see it anymore which makes
sense but it's kind of cool anyway
whoa
i like that that's cool hey look uh gen
c these are the houses you guys can
afford in the future
congrats oh my god that's so irritating
oh my god you did not did elon like stop
you did not do healing like that what
the
it looks normal upside down oh my god
[Laughter]
hell yeah
excuse me miss is this woman bought them
in you it's my [ __ ] friend
okay we got two cubes all right i'm fine
with it
no no where did tiny cube go you
murdered him oh he's okay he's okay
all right cool these are two perfectly
geometrical circles oh yeah
i'll be the judge of that oh yeah oh
oh yeah all right are they are they now
uh
all right it's this guy again what does
he have to say is not what you think it
is
you're probably seeing an old music
concert right well what it
actually is is just a rug underneath the
table
what is the friend to freak him out oh
my god it is
i didn't see the light god damn you rug
on the table who took this photo
oh i had a moment like this recently
actually when i was looking at cars i
was looking at japanese cars
and i saw hold up
whoop all right there goes my light we
have a professional
setup here all right i won't say what it
is but uh
i showed it to myself and she didn't see
it and then i showed it to ken and he
didn't see it either
so maybe i'm just crazy here we go here
it is uh i wrote marzia look this car
comes with like a fireplace
and she's like bruh that's an orchestra
come on am i the only one that saw that
god damn it
brain so dom got a six pack that's so
cool like it comes with a fireplace
this picture is not what you think it is
it's a stone
it's a stone ocean it's a sun no it's a
stone actually it's a stone
again stupid cake this photo is
completely black and white but has
colored lines on top of it this tricks
your brain to think the photo is colored
when you zoom out this one's crazy i can
see all the different colors
shut up shut up i gotta try this shut up
mate
i don't believe it i don't bloody
believe it mate
okay i know exactly how we can test this
grayscale
uh photoshop file done all right putting
it in
you [ __ ] liar you piece of [ __ ] oh i
totally
are you serious oh because of the color
line of course my bang then how do i
know
there's no way for me to know
it's a monkey monkey
monkey i saw monkey what else can you
see
god people like this my man why
did you see first if you saw
if you said that i saw the elderly
couple other musicians first it means
that you're more quiet and studious than
your friends but you're also more
creative and ambitious
if you saw the old couple first it means
that you're very trusting honest and
you're looking for a long-term
relationship like
i'm looking for that yeah please help me
what the [ __ ] these are so stupid you
don't know my brain get out of my brain
stupid brain anyway this has been
optical illusions pretty fun i enjoyed
it and if you did as well like subscribe
consider subscribing
profess see you tomorrow